m'encourager il me disait petit vase y
fonce
danielle oderra était dans la vingtaine
lorsqu'elle a rencontré brel par le
truchement de sa soeur qui était
propriétaire d'une boîte à chansons où
se retrouver toute la jeunesse
artistique de l'époque
d'ailleurs dès fois que les règles
étaient obligés de lui dire belle écoute
moi là tu vois que leur île et si je
ferme pas à 3 heures une femme enlevée
ma licence qu'est ce que je fais autant
le fait pas on a en a qui on arrive des
fois ça durer jusqu'à cinq
aussi elle a fait sa première partie le
15e de soir la comédie canadienne
devenue tnm avant de parcourir le québec
à ses côtés lors d'une grande tournée on
disait quand on fait ce métier il faut
qu'on ait la discipline du petit soldat
et son art à montréal brel retrouver des
amis pour briller
il ya des choses plus importantes que
l'amour passion c'est l amour amitié
lorraine pintal l'a vu lors de son
passage dans la métropole en 1967 la
manière dont ils vivaient chaque chanson
c'est un acteur c'est clair aussi donc
le fait que ce soit un comédien aussi
qui prête son talent un as et à sa
poésie
voilà
malin
j'ai des choses que je peux pas révéler
mais ça fait partie des rumeurs jacques
brel on le sait est un homme qui adorait
les femmes et les femmes la d'horaires
une chose est sûre son style et sa verve
ont fait des petits
j'ai toute une génération chant seigner
ne me quitte pas chaque chanson avait sa
propre univers où on a l'impression
d'assister à un tour de chant qui est un
peu comme du cinéma
si vous voulez chaque chanson le
spectacle musical
amsterdam est une biographie fictive qui
nous plonge dans la jeunesse du grand
chanteur belge
assurément brel et immortel et pour les
comédiens qui ressuscite son oeuvre au
tnm
son fantôme continue de rôder jeu c'est
vrai que j'ai eu une vague de frissons
avec la mais j'aime ça croire à ça ça
nourrit beaucoup d'enjeu ici nabi
alexandre charti radio canada montréal
[Musique]